[Music]
welcome to ball hatak in Belgium No
welcome to bar on the South in the
Netherlands Belgium okay everyone please
calm down it's both
welcome to the town with one of the most
intricate borders in the whole world
[Music]
Aurel is a quiet small town with not
much going on until you look at these
crosses yep that's an international
border and so is that and so is that
barlas home to a living border puzzle
instead of one border crossing there are
dozens of that and that's because the
town consists of 30 enclaves there are
22 pieces of Belgium surrounded by the
Netherlands and 10 dust areas in Belgium
the border goes through houses shops
beer stores and this means that there
are two of almost everything for a
population of under 10,000 to postal
services to churches to bus companies to
legal drinking ages there are even two
mayo toppings at this chicken shop yep
this one Dutch and him this one's
Belgium and there's two town halls and
of course a meeting room with a border
line in it and two separate
representatives so how did the town get
into this messy situation a safe text
America minutes filleted and m12 the air
would exchange from a friend Hector from
rabbits and roads dealer from little bit
over to Hoefler and here from breda
refurbished charming and later on this
meant that the Duke of Brabant possessed
Belgian lands and the Lord of Breda
Dutch lands as your installed LED
halyard artistry diversity important
native avenue san lorenzo official
foster cells foster new field a girl who
stayed to stamp cylinder gaminess
talking with her esophagus listening
edema she taped over they here i should
have over lifting i should have both
latina leering that would have examined
all right Anna Schwartz here Mase it's
failing
got it so head of tourism Willem how do
you know where your house is
if the border goes through it we have a
four door rule and the frontal home says
there where your front door is that is
the place where you have your
but what about front doors that get
chopped off by the border like this one
that's an exception living there you you
can choose but both ways rose-like
gallery owner Sylvia this is Belgium
this is no ants and this is my gallery I
have chosen from Belgium because I was
living in Belgium my company was better
so I take the easiest way all right
but the International commute it must be
tiring right cafe manager Willem of
course my cafe is at the Dutch side
I am Belgian so I cross the border every
day but I live here too we look meters
from so it's not that far
okay so my last question it has to be
this which town is best borrow hair tug
or borrow NASA
I prefer boat I'm Dutch and to be honest
I liked the way of living more in the
belt inside in the end it doesn't matter
which side of the border you choose all
in all this is just a great love story
between two countries every one of the
four inside at the bottom of affordable
central Commodore see two passers-by
cadenza goal for the problem is that we
have learned to deal with each other we
have learned to live with each other and
I could say your example for the rest of
[Music]
los primeros I know DC on Amiga y'know
c'mere tortilla y'know camara : on day I
say fueron communicant oh no al otro KDE
a 7d a comedian a chief welcome o m-pesa
Rhonda Yaga no dicen el es un poquito de
Amiga
[Music]
mean hombres Rosie Castillo e Co cinemas
comedian like in a lunch area booze
Latinos vijnana pere foucault Estados
Unidos pero es hora de encontrar una
mala noticia que ya no los de Karan pasa
muchos se dieron kadar cnt1 nosotros
somos los primeros Angus Oerlikon
mirakian muchos de chillon Amiga Yo no
tengo dinero no Trejo des amo la comida
tambien a los primary Tito's seprieono
mucho el seguro muchos Sinden arrows in
ropa por que se no Romano todo y por no
tremie Co V cos Y D Mo's Kobe hisagi
Rita ya Samos Balio Scioscia self uno
LRO's Blanco Ponzo [ __ ] Man II today
Puerco en leg in la mayoría que la
comida esta cosa si o si comme em
picante pero no homo nosotros locum emma
sunda sono said muy diferente a la de
nosotros hay algo que hay una caída to
tierra y que sabe que que lo vas a comer
algo de two pies from muchas veces no
dicen diwali tal vez es e esa forma de
vecinos casino Sentra sentimiento SI los
últimos que si fuera de niro he knows
Dobbin las Gracia leggo no ego con que
yo me stays at Yahoo stock ustedes se
van contentos con esos Pagano
[Music]
produce industry does not have the right
to dump nutritious product that can go
to families who are in need
[Music]
Borderlands food bank rescues between 30
to 40 million pounds of produce annually
and we've been doing it for 21 years
[Music]
my name is Yolanda Soto and I am the CEO
president of Borderlands Food Bank we
are an organization that rescues fresh
produce we get it to families all over
the state of Arizona and 19 other states
within the nation we saw there was a
tremendous amount of fresh produce
coming across at our port of entry here
from Mexico and a lot of it could not be
sold it could be because it had some
scarring it could be because it had some
rain stain and so they were actually
dumping it in the landfill we saw that
the product was extremely good for human
consumption
so we began educating the produce
industry
we've gone to each individual
distributor we've offered them our
services and said do not dump allow us
to rescue it and get it to families so
that they can eat nutritiously the
driver comes back to the warehouse he's
got a trailer load of product and he
begins to get unloaded we take up the
produce to the sites and we set it up
like a farmers market all done by
volunteers from the host site for a $10
contribution the supporter can select 60
pounds of produce pretty good 17 cents a
pound it's important to us to get it to
as many families as possible before it
perishes because I think that people
have the right to eat nutritiously it's
the most basic of needs thank you we
have the responsibility to stop waste
and we have the responsibility to help
the people in our own backyard
[Music]
my mom is amazing person yeah Lilith we
all agree we carry new phone
jeanette Caston yan and Rosario Vargas
are a mother and daughter separated by a
border one living in San Diego and the
other in Mexico
I came from Mexico 2006 because I want
to get another opportunities for my cats
cuando se bueno en si no me destory de
penser came it was la vie de la Volpe
Ramesh
I don't have the permission to cross the
border the line from the last
year-and-a-half I see my mom to the
fence at the sight of a by National Park
in San Diego the u.s. Border Patrol
allows families to meet on the weekends
loved ones enter the park and walk
directly up to the border a steel fence
this gives families on both sides a rare
opportunity to see and speak to each
other
no veo el Circo a partake a mere a
tristeza made Alegria porque voy Avera
mija you know you're gonna see your mom
you're gonna see your family but offense
and they have a tiny holes and my mom
sometimes put the finger in the tiny
hole I just a little touch it just touch
it or something I give you a kiss
esta muy cerca a la vez tan lejos from a
poor family in sympathy with Akira Mucha
on April 30th for the third time ever
authorities agree to open the door
allowing select families a brief moment
to embrace each of them will only have
three minutes
boys are not come home a bias until our
momento take it up with our Asajj they
get wasted whole day right now I feel so
happy because I'm waiting and waiting so
much this moment
[Music]
[Music]
I feel incredible she was so happy she
was so sweet with me she tell me I love
you mommy I love you so much I love you
I love you
[Applause]
[Music]